[Musique]
2021 c'est d'abord un espoir sortir de
la crise sanitaire
c'est ensuite un enjeu l'enjeu c'est la
préparation des élections territoriales
et gagner les élections territoriales
après avoir gagné les élections
municipales et puis enfin c'est un
objectif
l'objectif c'est la préparation des
élections présidentielles de 2022 alors
oui que 2021 nous offre un nouveau
chemin d'espérance que nous puissions
2021 réhabiliter les valeurs de travail
et de prospérité plutôt que l'esprit de
rente et d'assistanat encourageons et et
contention tous nos travailleurs nos
entrepreneurs nos artisans aux
commerçants
nos ouvriers nos caissier nos livreurs
nos personnels soignants toutes celles
et ceux aux fonds qui permettent à la
france de se tenir tout je voudrais
aussi vous remercie tout au long de
l'année vous avez fait preuve d'un sens
de la responsabilité d'autant plus
louable qu'il n'a pas toujours été payés
de rupture mais l'important est de
continuer d'avancer
c'est le voeu que je forme pour 2020
terre que nous avancions ensemble vers
la concrétisation nos espoirs sont à
votre pays qu'ils ne perdent pas de vue
les valeurs et si chère à son coeur
des valeurs de la république c'était
public que nous devons tenir fièrement
qui ne doit pas vaciller les valeurs de
fraternité et de solidarité
sûrement que en 2021 peut-être plus que
jamais nous aurons besoin de cette
solidarité en défendant avec passion et
sincérité nos convictions
je suis persuadé que nous serons ouvrir
une page 9
tout prête à recevoir les récits de nos
réussites individuelles et collectives
vous pouvez compter sur mon engagement
plein et entier
joyeuses fêtes à tous mes chers amis je
vous souhaite une excellente année 2021
à vous et à tous ceux que vous aimez et
puis prenez soin de votre santé et
prenez soin de la santé de ce vous aimez
de lorraine je vous adresse les
meilleurs voeux de santé et de
prospérité que 2021 nous permet de nous
retrouver enfin dans les salles pour
pouvoir échanger débattre et partager
nos convictions au service de la france
une nouvelle espérance se décide avec
2021 je veux vous souhaiter le meilleur
le meilleur pour cette nouvelle année le
meilleur pour vous le meilleur pour vos
proches pour vos familles pour tous ceux
que vous aimez
nous souhaitons un nouveau départ
rapidement tourner la page de cette
crise à la fois économiques et
sanitaires que l'on puisse à nouveau se
retrouver entre amis en famille c'est le
voeu le plus cher de forme ont chacun
d'entre vous et pour nous tous l'année
2000 21 ça doit d'abord être celle où
les enjeux français sont posés sur la
table et notamment ceux de la lutte
contre le séparatisme islamistes qui
menacent l'unité la banque française
je vous souhaite une belle et heureuse
année 2021
l'engagement plein d'audace plein de
courage il nous en faudra pour nous
reconstruire reconstruire notre société
rebâtir tout ce qui fait le plaisir de
vivre ensemble en france à la française
c'est ça que je souhaite pour 2021
l'année 2020 nous aura permis de
constater le rôle essentiel de nos
milliers de corps dès qu'il s'agisse des
personnels soignants ont des salariés
dans les chaînes logistiques et les
services publics
je profite de ses voeux pour leur rendre
hommage je souhaite que 2021 rime avec
courage ambitions et volonté de
reconstruire et relancer notre beauté
2021 je l'espère cela rime pas avec nous
c'est le début
d'alors est difficile mais très
prometteur chemin à la fois pour notre
famille politique je l'espère un chemin
d'unité et de projets
chemin de votre enfant aussi pour la
france après l'année inédite difficile
que nous venons de passer je nous
souhaite évidemment collectivement une
année d'espérance de bonne santé et de
justice dans notre pays
l'année 2000 21 devrait être placée sous
le signe de la solidarité solidarité
envers nos soignante que jamais
mobilisés depuis le premier jour de
cette crise sanitaire que vous souhaitez
très très bonnes années 2000 21 qui je
l'espère rimera avec l'humain destin des
républicains après une année 2000 m
particulièrement anxiogène je souhaite à
chacune et chacun d'entre vous une
magnifique année 2021 tout le bonheur
possible je forme le voeu que l'année
2010 21 soit couronnée de succès succès
dans la lutte contre l'épidémie de colo
19 succès dont notre famille politique
lors des élections départementales et
régionales de juin prochain
bonne année 2021 à tous meilleurs voeux
et pour moi et pour nous tous et
j'espère d'une attaque cardiaque de
l'espoir et du retour de la pensée
excellente année 2021 à toute cette
housse année je souhaite à tous points
de vue synonyme de reconquête je vous
souhaite
je nous souhaite notre famille politique
pour notre beau pays
le meilleur pour 2009 elle est heureuse
année je vous souhaite une belle année
2021 tous ensemble soyons réunis
rassemble est plus fort pour répondre
aux enjeux de demain
très belle année 2021 à tous avec
surtout une très bonne santé
bonne année à tous je vous souhaite une
excellente année 2021
plein de réussite de succès et de joie
partagée je vous souhaite à tous une
excellente année 2031
je vous souhaite à toutes et à tous une
excellente et ses belles années
très belle année
très belle et heureuse année bonne et
heureuse année 2010
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sont ils
[Musique]